we're back with more drew's news and a
special guest she has a hilarious
stand-up who you first met on crazy
ex-girlfriend and now she's part of the
stellar cast returning for season two of
doll face take a look at this clip my
entire class applied to work for this
bank how long until you accept your
inevitable future of being a beautiful
billionaire genius
ready
okay
very triggering that that fits our girl
is back she's come on home without my
cell i felt alone i mean we were here
the whole time please welcome
[Music]
okay
first of all i was watching your
stand-up special and i i highly suggest
everyone
run do not walk it's called hot form my
name and it is so amazing and so funny
it's on paramount plus
and who none other than someone i i
also stand for
um through nick goosen who i know how do
you know that's great oh i know nico's
in forever
i cannot believe you know nick first of
all he's one of my best friends and one
day nick called me and he says hey i
just showed adam sandler your stand-up
and he
said he wants to produce your special
and i was like well nick i don't have a
special and he's like adam says you're
ready you're ready let's go so don't
take my word for it
take adam sandler's word who knows
comedy better than anyone saw your work
and immediately said let's produce a
special let's make it happen and i've
been watching it i'm dying it's so good
you guys
it's so good it's so nice but it's true
and it's such an art you know thank you
and he's such a
he's such a warm wonderful person like
he's exactly who you think he would be
yeah and he's even helping us make a
movie me and nick wrote a movie together
and adam is producing it for us so he's
just been like so generous and wonderful
all right let's get into some stories um
esther do you want to take our next
story please i would love to
so next we've got another nighttime
skincare routine that's real hot right
now this one comes from tick tock style
caster reports people are swearing by
frowny's facial patches you can buy a
pack for twenty dollars and fans say
they erase wrinkles overnight like botox
in a face pack really
what do we think i want that
how do they work
i've never heard of this
do we what drew do you know about these
my mother
wore them out everywhere when i was a
kid out of the house
everywhere
yeah everywhere like this did i do it
right
yep you can do it that way she wore it
uh pointy side up oh my god mom if
you're watching
doing your frownies all you want
esther what do you think
i just want to put these on and then i
want to know if i'm finally hotter than
my sister yet
someone tell me
okay esther pavitsky the season two of
doll face premieres this friday
and please watch our stand-up special on
paramount plus it is one of the best
things i've seen in so long oh my god
that's true
i love you thank you so much
[Music]